somebody must have canceled today did
somebody cancel today oh Adrian wrote it
what's the name no no one canceled no I
got the text I'm like [__] yeah dude
when did you get when you when do you
get taxed I think about 20 minutes ago
no what no when was he booked no I think
a couple days ago yeah yeah I heard your
Nanny on the list yeah yeah do you guys
say it or or you guys are like get him
in oh yeah oh let's go yeah yeah well I
mean you know I have to approve it yeah
yeah right I mean I can't have like you
know Kevin Shea walk in here you know
what I mean
would do our show or do you think that
um I think she she definitely would she
was like so shy and just kind of like
very just like like the fact that she
does porn like I forgot like she was
like yeah I'm going back to law school
and I was like oh yeah I've seen this
category before yeah I mean when you
talk to them they sometimes they go you
know sometimes we do scenes for three
hours they [__] for three hours wow and
then you guys don't
who's like Asians or Koreans or big nose
folks big nose big nose no I'm saying
when you when you just said you guys
don't what did you mean by that no no no
no no no no no no come back to when you
said we were in the green no no no no no
no no no I want to get back to this sick
I said no no listen listen just listen
for a second okay all right all right
we talked about I mean three hour sex
and then you said you guys don't but
then his fingers sort of only pointed to
John you me and Gilbert but he missed me
he missed George so when you said you
guys don't can we come to a commercial
break yeah yeah hello fresh does that
mean no I'm saying
in specifically like like you people
we're not dating you people I know I
know that specifically you people no no
no no no no no no I'm saying is it
Asians in generals jungle Asians is it
Inland Asian he's an inland Nation
there's snow Asians you know the eskimos
yeah yeah there's all kinds of Asians
I'm saying
how do I refer Bobby and kalila yeah
there we go okay yeah all right all
right gotta say names man so that's what
you're saying Bobby and Clyde you guys
did three hours for three hours oh my
God one time in Sacramento that's a
place
oh yeah yeah Sacramento
hotel room yeah that's exactly it there
was only mattress stores and whatever
yeah and then we were just like I think
one night we were just like oh let's
just say we [__] for three hours sober
odd yeah yeah let's go three hours yeah
I love that club in Sacramento the punch
line do you like it it's so fun great
audience right my car got broken into
there at a Chick-fil-A which is the
holiest place in the world I had a
rental car doing one-nighters up the
coast did Sac punch and then somebody
punched in the car and it was a rental
or you're on a rental yeah oh wow at a
Chick-fil-A broad daylight whoa that's
pretty bold I when I get a rental now I
don't walk